[Music]
every television fan gets used to the
pain of seeing their favorite series
cancelled sometimes though the plug gets
pulled for reasons that were totally
avoidable and sometimes even downright
dumb the ' 60s Batman series starring
Adam West isn't anyone's idea of
hard-hitting superhero entertainment but
it's a campy classic and one that might
have stayed on the air longer than 2
years if the network hadn't gotten a
destructive itch execs at ABC weren't
willing to continue funding Batman after
its first two seasons so they decided to
sell the rights to NBC meanwhile NBC
wanted to make sure Batman's existing
sets and props were part of the deal
unfortunately during a brief production
Hiatus between networks and ABC exec had
the sets destroyed the deal died and the
Caped Crusader hung up his cowl Jonas
Armstrong star of BBC 1's Robin Hood
decided to vacate the lead role after
the show's third season but instead of
recasting the part with a new actor The
Producers opted to Simply kill off the
character since they'd already killed
off Robin's love made Maran that left
The Supporting Cast to carry the show
you know the one named after a guy who
was dead although Robin Hood's writing
staff was willing to try a revamp the
network decided there was no point in
continuing when Warner Brothers hit Pay
Dirt with young Justice which posted
triple digit ratings increases for its
time slot on Cartoon Network it seems
safe to assume they'd want more than two
seasons but the show was axed after only
46 episodes prompting outcry and
widespread speculation despite great
ratings the real reason it was cancelled
was frustrating to its fans funding for
the show came from a merchandising
tie-in deal for Young Justice action
figures from Mattel but when low sales
killed the toy line the show quickly
followed suit it's unfair when a show
that's supposed to be a 30 minute toy
commercial is actually pretty great but
the toys aren't few places are scarier
than hospitals so in horror Maestro
Stephen King made a deal with ABC to
write and produce the haunted medical
drama Kingdom hospital it seemed like a
perfect fit sadly the show's Soul season
was kind of a mess not on screen where
it offered a solid batch of episodes
that earned two Emmy nominations but
behind the scenes where struggles
between king and the network doomed it
convinced ABC wasn't promoting Kingdom
Hospital enough King paid for a print ad
campaign only to see his efforts foiled
when exec moved it to a different time
slot King learned yet again that while
ghosts are scary what's truly terrifying
is dealing with network
Executives after Buffy the Vampire
Slayer ended in 2003 fans flocked to the
show's spin-off angel
which was entering its fifth season
after years on the renewal bubble Angel
enjoyed a post Buffy ratings bump series
Creator Jos Weeden approached WB Network
president Jordan Levan about an early
pickup for season 6 although weeden's
move wasn't purely a power play he was
looking for extra security for Angel's
team who' endured years of passing up
gigs while waiting for last minute
renewals Levan saw it as an ultimatum
the president pulled the plug all for
the sake of throwing his weight around
although the network later admitted it
was a mistake it was too late to revive
Angel lots of movies are made out of TV
shows but the three Naked Gun movies
probably Mark the first time a
successful series of films respond from
an incredibly unpopular TV show nice
Bieber thank you I just had it stuffed
let me help you with that filled with
sight gags and recurring jokes police
squad start starring Leslie neelen as
Lieutenant Frank dban hit the airwaves
in 1982 and was pulled after just four
episodes with the remaining two burned
off over the summer ABC president Tony
tomopoulos was surprisingly Frank about
why people weren't tuning in he told a
reporter that the viewer had to watch it
to appreciate it that's right police
squad asked that its audience try that
crazy thing where they pay attention to
what's happening on the screen
apparently the jokes on ABC's hit shows
happy days and the loveboat were so
simple they could be understood by
[Music]
osmosis pulling in roughly 3 to 5
million viewers per week long Meer was
A&E's most watched original drama ever
and was among the top rated dramas on
cable TV during its three season run yet
the network canceled it anyway why
because most of those fans were too damn
old yes TV networks are pretty much only
interested in courting the key 18 to 49
demographic which advertisers think is
the easiest group to part from their
money so because long Meyer's audience
wasn't gullible enough A&E canel it no
worries though the show is picked up by
Netflix which doesn't have to worry
about advertising
Trends during the 1969 1970 TV season
CBS chief of programming Fred Silverman
noticed that the show's getting the best
advertising rates for ABC and NBC shows
aimed at Young And Hip viewers with
Multicultural casts in urban
environments cbs's shows on the other
hand were mostly rural family shows
Silverman's solution cancel all his farm
shows and replace them with cuttingedge
new city sitcoms out went the Red
Skelton Show Petticoat Junction Green
Acres Lassie and the gym neighbors hour
replacing them honest to goodness class
Classics including the Mary Tyler Moore
Show All in the Family Good Times mod
and the Bob newart show ratings surged
among younger demographics and
Silverman's move became Hollywood Legend
known Ever After as the great rural
Purge for 26 years Lavar Burton's
beloved Reading Rainbow helped kids
develop a love of reading but in 2009
budget restrictions forced the show's
cancellation because it wasn't educating
kids in a government improved fashion
weird right well it all started with the
No Child Left Behind Act signed into law
in2 it sought to establish new
educational benchmarks for American Kids
many of which would be measured with
standardized test results in that box is
the
bill I don't intend to read it all
that's fine for quantifiable skills but
it's hard to measure love of reading on
a standardized test so there went the
funding the Prime video series A League
of Their Own based on the 1992 movie of
the same name was set to conclude with a
second season only four episodes long
half the length of season 1 the short
length was odd given that the show's
co-creator Will Graham posted on X
formerly Twitter shortly after the
season 2 announcement that the women's
baseball show had more viewers than
other series that received full renewals
from Amazon yet even that a bridged
ending is no longer happening with
League of Their Own season 2 being
cancelled in August 2023 amidst the wga
and sag after strikes the official
reasoning given for the cancellation was
that the strikes would have delayed
production in 2024 and the release in
2025 resulting in a three-year gap
between seasons of course fans would
have been much happier waiting 3 years
for a conclusion than getting none at
all Abby Jacobson the show's star and
other co-creator wrote on Instagram to
blame this cancellation on the strike
which is an essential fight for fair
wages protections and working conditions
Etc is cowardly at the same time Amazon
Studios pulled the plug on season 2 of A
League of Their Own they gave the same
treatment to season 2 of the peripheral
according to the Hollywood Reporter some
insiders at Amazon believed the Sci-Fi
series based on the novel by William
Gibson shouldn't have been renewed in
the first place the reason the original
season's $175 million budget was in
stark contrast to its lukewarm audience
response however justifiable cancelling
the peripheral after season 1 might have
been cancelling season 2 after already
greenlighting it was a bad Omen for the
future of Studio Talent relations not
long after the show's cancellation
announcement show producers Lisa Joy and
Jonathan Nolan's development deal with
Amazon was suspended unlike many
canceled shows the animated fantasy
series The Owl House managed to get a
satisfying ending though it was
significantly condensed from a full
third season to just 3H hourong specials
with ratings on par with other ongoing
Disney Channel shows and a passionate
online fan base Why didn't it get its
full three season run Creator Dana
Terrace said on Reddit that someone at
Disney decided the show didn't fit
Disney's brand at the end of the day
there are a few business People Who
oversee what fits into the Disney brand
and one day one of those guys decided to
didn't fit that brand the story is
serialized our audience skews older and
that just didn't fit this one guy's
taste really grinds my guts boils my
brain kicks my shins all the things it
sucks but it is what it is what exactly
about the owl house was considered UND
Disney Terrace initially pushed back
against the theory that the show's LGBT
plus representation led to the
cancellation but after news of Disney
initially donating to politicians
backing Florida's don't say gay Bill she
was less charitable in her
analysis Cartoon Network's OK KO Let's
Be Heroes also had its third and final
season cut short from the original plan
for the series according to Creator Ian
Jones qute the dumb decision that led to
the action comedy cartoon's premature
ending was not made by the network but
by the former president of the United
States OK KO was made with the intention
of premiering on a streaming service
formed by the merger of Warner Brothers
and AT&T basically what became HBO Max
Jones cord said in a 2021 interview with
creative Talent Network Donald Trump
specifically hated Warner Brothers
because they own CNN so he wouldn't let
that merger go through basically what
happened is the studio basically got
stuck in a holding pattern while they
were waiting for this merger to go
through the president denied the the
merger five simple words that have a
really significant meaning with all the
delays in the merger OK KO ended up
airing its entire run on Cartoon Network
well before the launch of HBO Max
restrictions on spending during the
waiting period for the mergers approval
ultimately led to the show's early
cancellation and reportedly impacted
much of what was being made at Cartoon
Network Studios a studio that no longer
exists as an independent
entity the Anthology setup of Infinity
train with each season or book dealing
with different characters facing their
problems in the same setting could have
theoretically let the show run for well
infinity or at least as long as the
writers wanted Creator Owen Dennis had
plans for eight seasons But ultimately
Infinity train ended after four seasons
the logic behind the cancellation makes
little sense given that Infinity train
was the fourth most streamed HBO Max
original of 2020 it also seemed seemed
to have been caught up in wildly
fluctuating corporate mandates a vulture
article from May 2022 stated Cartoon
Network was seeking out young adult
oriented content and infinity train was
perfect for that space just 3 months
after that article the Mandate seemingly
shifted again with HBO Max deleting
Infinity train and 35 other mostly
animated series a move Dennis wrote on
substack was incredibly unprofessional
rude and just straight up
slimy how many TV shows get canceled
because of protests from people who've
never watched them in a country where
it's not even airing this was the
strange fate of Clone High the 2002 MTV
cartoon created by Bill Lawrence Phil
Lord and Christopher Miller the show's
main characters are all teenage clones
of famous historical figures and
Gandhi's clone responds to the pressure
of living up to one of History's
Greatest leaders by not even trying
instead behaving as a a wacky party
animal don't get on that
plane yet First Take This demo to give
to Ashley Angel from oown E Clone High
never aired in India but seeing the
character's bio on the MTV website was
enough to spark a hunger strike of 150
politicians and the real Gandhi's
grandson at the MTV India offices the
show's creators had two possible
solutions in response to the controversy
they were willing to continue the show
without gandi or they could make a quick
adjustment so the gandi character was
actually a Gary Coleman clone and then
continue as usual alas the Viacom
higher-ups rejected both options and
canceled the show instead two decades
later it returned gandi free on Max in
2023 the fact that Firefly only lasted
one season might very well have
contributed to its cult favorite status
given that some of the planned episode
ideas for Firefly season 2 sound flat
out awful as well as other serious
problems that have come to light
regarding Creator Jos Weeden maybe it's
for the best that it ended while it was
still good still it feels like Firefly
was treated unfairly during its run on
Fox from the beginning the fox
Executives disliked that Zoe and wash
were married and had contradictory
requests over how dark and violent the
show should be it was scheduled for the
Friday night death slot and hyperactive
comedy Centric advertisements didn't
match the tone of the show perhaps the
worst sign of how the show was set up to
fail was that the pilot episode was
somehow changed to the season finale and
three episodes didn't air on Fox at all
shiny let's be bad guys an unusually
mature action-oriented standout of the
Disney Afternoon lineup gargoyles was
popular enough that CEO Michael Eisner
asked series Creator Greg wisman about
using it as the launching pad for a
whole franchise but ratings in the
second season declined and a toned down
third season made by a different crew
for Saturday mornings flat out flopped
big Ambitions followed by disappointment
can be a pretty normal cycle for TV
shows but there's one factor in this
decline that makes things weird the OJ
Simpson trial the second season of
gargoyles kept getting preempted by OJ
trial coverage on many of the stations
that ran the Disney Afternoon in
syndication wisan told polygon every day
it ran we were being preempted and in
any given City people were missing
episodes of gargoyles and falling out of
the habit of watching it gordita
Chronicles a sitcom about a family of
Dominican immigrants in 1980s Miami got
universally positive reviews and was
building word of mouth on HBO Max in the
summer of 2022 only to get cancelled a
little over a month after its Premiere
it was later removed from the streaming
service entirely HBO Max's official
statement on the cancellation read in
part liveaction kids and family
programming will not be part of our
programming focus in the immediate
future and as a result we've had to make
the very difficult decision to end
gordita Chronicles at HBO Max a year
later HBO Max rebranded to just Max in
hopes of appealing more to family
audiences and it seems like gordita
Chronicles was lost due to some severely
confused priorities Creator Bridget
munes lioz told Rolling Stone it felt
very unjust it didn't matter that our
show was beloved it didn't matter that
we had good audience numbers it didn't
matter that we were writing about
content that was important for
underrepresented communities none of
that mattered Warner Brothers
discoveries gutting of TBS and TNT
reached its peak on July 11
2022 that was the day season 2 of Chad a
comedy starring Saturday Night Live Alum
Nim pedod was supposed to Premiere only
for the show to get cancelled and pulled
from TBS s that very same day at least
the series would eventually be rescued
from completely disappearing thanks to
the Roku channel can you just please
find it in your little heart to make a
special exception just this once all the
corporate statements in the world about
how networks celebrate the creators of
completed shows they're refusing to air
doesn't change just how unfair the whole
practice is Chad was a show that got
mostly good reviews from critics and had
a strong viewership but was targeted
online with sexist and islamophobic
review bombing which only served to
further embolden online trolls Ellen
degenerous may have been in the wrong
with how she treated her talk show staff
which led to the end of her talk show
The Ellen degenerous Show but when it
came to the end of her '90s sitcom Ellen
it was the ABC Executives who were at
fault the star comedian famously came
out as gay with season Four's
groundbreaking two-parter the puppy
episode has there ever been anyone you
felt you clicked with
and what was his
name Susan in 1997 this was
controversial enough that ABC put
parental discretion warnings for adult
content over many episodes of season 5 a
move which upset degenerous Network
Executives reportedly feuded with
degenerous over how much gay content to
include in season 5 which ultimately
ended up being the show's final season
while declining ratings might offer a
rationalization for the cancellation
battles over just how gay the final
season could be look ridiculous in
retrospect with the launch of Disney
plus and the start of Marvel Studios
producing its own shows for the new
streaming service the Marvel TV series
formerly streaming on Netflix were
phased out but Daredevil the most
consistently popular of the Netflix
Marvel shows will eventually be making
its Grand return on Disney plus under
the new title Daredevil born again
with the stars of the Netflix show
returning this isn't a reboot so much as
a new season of the previous series but
former Daredevil showrunner Steven
denight says the name change is simply a
ploy to pay the crew at the rate of a
Show's first season rather than its
fourth he wrote on X it's an old Disney
scam where they slightly rename a series
to reset contract terms back to first
season needs to be addressed by all the
guilds unions and crushed the first time
the critic was cancelled in 1994 it made
sense scheduled after Home Improvement
on ABC it completely alienated the
audience and ratings declined
dramatically week after week despite
this initial failure the critic got a
second chance on Fox the following year
where it aired after The Simpsons and
retained a much higher percentage of its
leadin audience showing a lot of growth
you must build from a foundation of
trust and understanding if that doesn't
work tell her you have a tumor either
way way the key word is growth the
critic ended up as one of the more watch
shows on Fox that year but it was
canceled anyway why co-creator Mike
Reese said that the president of Fox at
the time John mat toyan just hated the
show Reese told cracked one day he
called us in for a meeting with the fox
brass and said I want to play an episode
of your show and I want you to tell me
what's funny he put the show on and it
started playing and all the younger
Executives were laughing reys explained
that even though the young Executives
knew they weren't supposed to laugh they
couldn't help it they were supposed to
not laugh and make the boss happy but
they were cracking up John mat toyan
turned around and went why are you
laughing mat toyan had the last laugh
though asking the show this magazine
says Jay is the wittiest man alive so
I'll tell you what I'm going to do watch
Jay for a month you don't laugh I pay
you a hundred bucks
when a show gets retooled so heavily
that the writers State their disdain for
making it in the theme song it's fair to
assume it's not long for this world such
is the case with pinky Elmyra and the
Brain the spin-off SL sequel to Pinky
and the Brain where the lab mice were no
longer plotting world domination at Acme
Labs but instead living with the animal
abusing tiny tune Adventures character
Elmyra Duff the WB didn't know what to
do with pinky in the brain a cartoon
more intellectual and adult skewing than
they wished their Saturday morning block
to be but also failed to become the next
Simpsons in Prime Time likely because it
was scheduled up against the long
running TV staple 60 Minutes on Sundays
at 7:00 p.m. according to ucks network
Executives thought the show needed a
broader cast of characters after three
seasons of the classic world domination
themes the network got its way and
nobody liked it effectively killing both
Pinky and the Brain and Steven Spielberg
B's long run of collaborations with
Warner Brothers animation despite their
best laid plans what are we going to do
tomorrow night the same thing we do
every night pinky try to take over the
world advertising for the 2010 FX series
Terriers heavily featured angry dogs and
the show's logo which is based around a
dog bone so what's the show actually
about you guessed it it's a buddy
detective show FX President John lra
attempted to downplay the impact bad
marketing had on the critical favorites
low ratings and ultimate cancellation in
talking with the Los Angeles Times he
argued that the show was just too subtle
for The Wider public to appreciate and
that no amount of marketing could have
helped it some 13 years later however
producer Shawn Ryan still maintains that
a vague title and bad marketing sealed
the show's fate not its subtlety he told
The Hollywood Reporter I blame myself
for not pushing better for a better
title and I think FX would admit that
they never got the marketing right on
that show there were an astounding 19
shows cancelled by the CW in 2022 and
2023 including hits like Riverdale Nancy
Drew the Flash The 4400 and More in fact
almost the entire network lineup was
nuked from orbit why this extreme House
Clearing in 2022 the majority of shares
in the CW were sold from previous
co-owners Paramount Global and Warner
brother's Discovery to nextstar Media
Group which canceled everything in an
attempt to boost profitability there's a
lot of dumb to go around here for
example the fact that the previous
owners were reportedly running a major
Network for 15 years without being
profitable which is either bad business
or extremely sketchy Hollywood
accounting there's also the dumb in
retrospect decision not to renew the
CW's lucrative deal with Netflix in 2019
but now nextstar is bringing in a
different sort of dumb as they've gutted
the network to put out more generic
reality shows
instead HBO's dazzling western series
Deadwood ended abruptly after three
seasons in 2006 the network wanted the
show to return offering Creator and
showrunner David milch a fourth season
but a shortened one milch wanted more
however and rather than taking an
abbreviated fourth season he told HBO no
thanks and Deadwood was cancelled
milch's impulsive decision and the HBO
Executives willingness to go along with
it took the rest of the show's cast and
crew by shock it marked a rare premature
cancellation in an era where HBO had a
positive reputation for letting shows
with low ratings but critical Acclaim
reached natural conclusions eventually
Deadwood did get a proper finale though
it was much shorter than even the
abbreviated fourth season would have
been Deadwood the movie aired on HBO in
2019 reuniting the majority of the
show's cast and earning near Universal
positive
reviews in 2009 chicago-based WGN was
rebranded as WGN America a general
interest station in the mold of USA or
TNT and began producing high quality
scripted dramas this collection included
underground which was centered around
the Underground Railroad the 19th
century network of abolitionists that
helped slaves escape the South
Underground brought critical Acclaim and
some of the best ratings WGN America had
ever seen despite its success though it
was canceled in 2017 after two seasons
Peter Kern president and CEO of WGN
America corporate parent Tribune media
said the show didn't fit with the
Network's new direction that new
Direction no more scripted original
series at all WGN America also scrapped
the appalation drama Outsiders when that
series got the axe Kern said the network
would be reallocated their resources at
the behest of Executives at Sinclair
broadcast Group which was in the process
of acquiring WGN America and all of
Tribune the reason was money Sinclair
was interested in making profits not
good TV Sinclair CEO Chris Ripley told
the Wall Street Journal the channel
could be run much more profitably on a
fraction of what they spend on
programming in other words underground
and Outsiders which cost a reported $5
million an episode were too expensive
iive among the most beloved CT TV shows
of all time Freaks and Geeks aired on
NBC during the 1999 to 2000 season for
the dramedy set in 1980 Jud appow and
Paul fig pulled from their own awkward
upbringings to create a show that was
emotionally honest and highly relatable
Freaks and Geeks was never a ratings hit
and NBC canceled it after 12 episodes
the executive who actually pulled the
trigger G aner visited the set of
Saturday Night Live in 2014 during a
week when Geeks cast member Seth Rogan
just happened to be there Rogan later
discussed the encounter on huff post
live in 2014 saying he and aner talked
about the premature cancellation
according to Rogan anier said that appat
refused to listen to his suggestions to
make the show better ancer's biggest
note he wanted the characters to get
more wins and stop being such big losers
all the time in other words he wanted
appau to abandon in the very essence of
the show's premise appow refused ratings
didn't improve and the network pulled
the plug fortunately that freed up a
stellar cast of future stars that
included Rogan James Franco Jason
seagull Linda Cardellini and many more
The Spiderwick Chronicles is a popular
children's book series that was adapted
into a popular 2008 feature film so the
six episode Disney plus miniseries
adaptation seemed On Solid Ground until
the network can canell it after it was
done filming but before it ever aired
it's particularly heartbreaking to think
about this from the perspective of the
show's young Stars lion Daniels and Noah
catrell imagine being a kid and spending
nearly 5 months of your life on a big
fantasy series based on a beloved story
that will likely set you on the path to
achieving your acting dreams then you
find out Disney wants to tax break and
it's well no one will ever see it making
matters more frustrating Katrell has
already lived through a similar version
of this disappointment thanks to HBO
Max's treatment of gordita
[Music]
Chronicles